-Welcome back to the show.
We used to talk when you used to
come on "Late Night,"
and you used to say like,
"Yeah, I'm going to be
going to space one day.
I'm going to go to space."
And you're doing it now.
You did it.
-Yeah, it was --
Many years
I think we did interviews,
and I would go "next year,"
"next year," "next year."
But anyway, finally it happened.
-Here you are in space.
-Yeah, it was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You said you were gonna do it,
and then you did it.
-It was the most extraordinary
day of my life.
And it was a real
"pinch me" moment.
And it's just --
I hope all of you one day
have the chance to go to space,
and that's our challenge.
-I mean, you think that --
You think that
there will come a day
where that...?
-Well, I think -- You know,
we're building
a number of spaceships,
another number of motherships.
And there are others
trying to do the same thing.
And I think in time
the price will come down
so that, you know,
hopefully more and more people
will have a chance,
but it'll be --
it'll be a number of years
before a lot of people
have a chance.
-What was your takeaway?
Were you scared at all?
-I wasn't scared for one second
of the whole day.
I just was so looking
forward to it.
And I had my kids
and grandkids there,
and it was just
a dream come true.
-The Virgin Group
does so many different things.
You do -- You go to space,
you have hotels,
you have cruise ships.
How do you decide what is the
thing you're gonna be into?
-Generally out of frustration
I mean, if I, I mean --
the way I started Virgin
Atlantic nearly 40 years ago
was I was trying to get
to the Virgin Islands.
I got bumped off a flight.
I went to the back of
the airport and hired a plane.
I went, got a blackboard,
I wrote as a joke,
"Virgin Airlines. One way.
$39 to the British
Virgin Islands."
Went out to all the passengers
that got bumped.
And I filled up my first plane.
And...
-That's -- Easy as that.
Now you have your own airline.
How many years ago was that?
-That was 39. 39 years ago.
-39 years ago. Yeah.
Still going strong.
-The next day, rang Boeing
and asked if they had
any secondhand 747s for sale.
-But this whole thing --
I've read your story,
and it's a fascinating story.
But from what I remember,
I think this whole thing started
with a necklace
that your mother found?
-Yeah, I was trying
to start a magazine
to campaign against
the Vietnamese War,
which, like most wars,
I thought was a very unjust war.
And -- And --
[ Applause ]
Uh...
And I was 15 going on 16.
I was working from
the school phone box.
And my mom found a necklace.
Because we didn't have
much money.
She handed it in to the police.
Nobody claimed it.
And I was given by my mum
the $200 to use in the phone box
to try to get the advertising
to start the magazine.
And that was, you know --
That was really our complete
funding to build the magazine,
then to start building
Virgin Records,
and one thing led on to another.
-Yeah. Wow.
-So, very grateful to my mum.
-Thank you, Mum. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Oh, that's wild.
-Yeah.
-Thank you to whoever was good
enough to leave their necklace.
-Yeah, exactly. Right.
And so now let's talk about
the hotel here in New York.
-Yeah, I mean, Virgin's
been flying to New York.
I mean, we have maybe 12 flights
a day to New York.
-It's most fun airline.
It's the best.
The colors are fun.
Everything's cool about it.
You go, "Yeah."
I always loved it.
-Well, thank you.
And when people
get off the plane,
they have to go
to dark and dingy hotels,
which I'm afraid quite a lot
of hotels in New York are.
There are some good ones.
And so we thought we'd open one
with massive windows
in every room,
beautiful views
of the Empire State Building
and the rest of New York,
and did it
with a delightful man
called John Lam.
And we're very, very, very
happy the way it's turned out.
-Where'd you open it?
-It's on Broadway,
and it's just off Times Square,
where we've had
quite a lot of history with,
you know, Virgin Megastores
and other things.
-I know you had the cast
of "New York, New York."
-We had the cast
out on the street today.
We rang up the police
and said, "Look.
Would you mind
closing the street
while we've got the cast
from 'New York, New York'"?
-They're like, "We're a little
busy today closing the streets.
Of all days? No! Tomorrow
we'll do it. Why today?"
-What they said was, "We've had
to close the rest of New York.
So what's one more street.?"
-[ Laughs ]
That is so funny.
That's funny. That's great.
-They gave us permission.
-That's great. Congratulations
on the new hotel.
And we always love
having you here.
You're such a great spirit.
Good to see you, buddy.
-Thank you.
-Sir Richard Branson.
Virgin Hotels New York City
is officially open now.
For more information,
go to VirginHotels.com/nyc.
More "Tonight Show" after the
break. Stick around, everybody.